[Music]
the Prime Minister this has been a
conference to forget for Liz trusses
conservative party it began with a
u-turn on giving a tax break to
Britain's richest and ended in a speech
on disruption that was itself disrupted
bringing it all to a close the Prime
Minister saying she is still ready to
make hard choices and do what it takes
as the last few weeks have shown it will
be difficult
whenever there's change there is
disruption and not everybody will be in
favor of change
but everyone will benefit from the
results
trust created a new enemy which he
called the anti-growth Coalition and
which basically includes anyone who
might oppose or protest against her
economic policies ten days before
conference started her government
announced massive tax cuts paid for by
Massive borrowing
as if On Cue a pair of climate
protesters from Greenpeace noisily
interrupted her before being ejected
from the hall
we're the only party and after just 34
minutes the finale together we can
unleash the full potential of our great
country that is how we will build a New
Britain for a new era
after four days of extraordinary tension
and party descent there was an almost
tangible sense of relief that it was
finally over senior conservatives accept
that this conference has been something
of an ordeal but trust has at least
survived it like
it's going to be discussions uh within
governments there always are right every
because every party is a kind of
standing Coalition of different digits
what you hope is that people have those
discussions in private then have a
unified line and unity is the key to
electoral success
it's been a torrid Party Conference for
prime minister Liz truss her response
has been to try to normalize the turmoil
to portray the disruption as a natural
perhaps even a necessary consequence of
the change that she says Britain so
badly needs
it is too early to judge whether Liz
trust has done enough to regain her
Authority and restore her credibility
the opinion polls still look Bleak for
the conservatives but in the words of
one departing delegate it wasn't a
disaster Paul Brennan Al Jazeera
Birmingham